all right Ali is where the sally's in
Texas hey Ali how are you hey better
than the night is there how are you guys
doing today
just the same how do we know all right
real quick mm around 2016 I am a lot of
work lost my job and was the faulted on
my credit loans and the Quecha so in law
firm from one of my creditors which is a
credit union called me and after I had
poured out my heart to the lady and she
was very nice and I offered to do a
payment plan or to do a settled amount
they wanted more than what I could
afford monthly and they wanted a lump
sum when I look at my credit I see that
the credit union is adding interest
payment so that even though it's
considered written off the amount keeps
going up monthly so I tell them when I
said hey I said hey here's the situation
I'm trying to set what the credit and
I'm trying to make right on it when I
tried to call and to make right on it in
the past I think could not unlock my
account I couldn't access it to get a
visual a lot of stuff happened and so
they're like well you have to go through
this law firm that leasing work for them
which is a debt collection law firm now
the law firm has added about 800 more
than the original amount what was the
original amount
it's 25 600 okay and now they've added
800 to that and whatever you wants what
did you offer them as a lump sum or what
did they offer you
I even offered to pay the 25 in full
what a credit union and as elder
community credit union it drew Oakland
for an HAML a firm and they don't seem
to be willing to do did you get a lump
sum offer from the attorney or did you
make one to the attorney
I made a lump sum offer to pay off but
they wanted everything how much is an
optional offer about working honey do
what I had at the time okay on a $3,200
debt that's not been paid on since 2016
right yeah that's a good offer
just keep offering it
call the Law Firm listen don't listen
don't have big personal discussions with
these people they don't they don't
really give a crap about you as a matter
of fact they don't give a crap at all
about anybody so all you're trying to do
is deal with a dog that will bite you
that is on the end of a chain and you're
trying to throw it a biscuit without
getting bit hmm
so that's how you treat these people
they're rattlesnakes they're not your
friends and you just you're just paired
a little bit more than the bigger bang
yeah you don't need to share nothing you
just say you have a very old debt you
have nothing now I'm offering you 1,400
a settlement in full my financial coach
told me that that is a great offer and
if you don't want to take it you will
get nothing do you want to take it I'll
call back next month and offer it again
or you can call me back any time and
decide you want to take it do you want
to take the 1,400 maybe and they banded
a man I have a man Amba hang up okay and
then call them back the next month and
do it again and then hang up and then
the next month do it again eventually
they're gonna go oh this lady has $1,400
and they will take it but get it in
writing and do not give them electronic
access to your checking account they can
continue to add interest on it even
though it is written off and they can
lock your accounts up because your
accounts in default of course they can
lock it up and not allow you access to
it so you got no rights here you got a
$3,200 debt including collection $800
where the collection fees which is
asinine and ridiculous but they're
trying it and then we're not gonna let
them pull that so you're offering them
1,400 bucks if you want to get up to
1600 and get it done that's fine or even
2,000 and get it done that's fine but
don't get into bidding against yourself
let them make you a good offer and
you're dealing with rattlesnakes
keep in mind this is very personal to
you this is their job and they have a
job that sucks
they get to do this all day yeah hmm who
would would you want to be you or them
I'd rather be you
hmm okay initially when you called you
were you you greeted us and you said hi
good to talk to you and then your voice
dropped octaves and you spoke as though
you're ashamed and I want you this
happened in 2016 you lost your job you
picked yourself back up you're trying to
settle and make things right hold your
head up high when you move forward okay
I really appreciate that because I have
helped I used to help a lot of people in
the financial industry right I wish I
knew then what I know now following the
Dave Ramsey show and the company was
doing a lot of unethical stuff they made
the news and I left taking a part-time
job making half the amount I was because
they didn't want you to go home unless
you had it in a longer lead or it was
just the pressure to sell so so sure and
I just thought credit unions Rebecca so
I really do appreciate your advice pick
your head up pick your head up and walk
with your head high yeah you're gonna
get this you're a warrior